have that
feeling I'm now going to do a
confirmatory exercise that I have the
feeling so he's going to push and I
don't try to not fall over because now
I'm activating my ego tripartite mind I
don't try to hold my arm still I stay in
the feeling of the change in
Consciousness I can use my kinesthetic
index points Temple chin
I can use the feeling of the
energetics but I'm more
interested in the feeling in the change
of
Consciousness because nothing Alters
once I understand the feeling in the
change of Consciousness I don't need the
energetics I don't need the the little
exercises I don't need
[Music]
them
we don't need
them and don't need
them so not depending remember the C you
the I sets are they're expedited they're
expedited me they shortcut so to speak
is that you got to be able to do this
it's a bare minimum
okay but they're meant to expedite your
progress in them you have to keep in
mind all the other stuff so don't make a
fetish out of the drill I just showed
you the point is to not need the drill
the point is to not need the movement to
not need the posture do you understand
okay so oh I'm going to do eeko for
example I don't try to do EO I don't try
to make his arm move I try to just enter
into the conscious state that I want my
hand is just the way that my the sword
my hand went up the sword went up the
sword came down I didn't make it go so
the same thing as I'm moving my hand is
just loose very relaxed you see that my
hand is
relaxed but it's not wimpy where I'm
going do you understand okay so so my my
hand is I'm going to leave my my hand
more like this so you can see okay or
just like I lift the sword okay don't
intend to lift my sword but I'm moving
just like drill one my my hand is
relaxed so just like he could he can't
push me and drill one he can't push me
either here you see because remember
there's no there was no need for the
form so he's he can't move me anywhere
in the cycle okay
got it so I as I come around to do it my
hand is
relaxed but it's not just him okay so
for
example um Margaret you can come you're
going to push me at that
angle get on the shoulder you're going
to push me okay so push there you go and
he's
pushing nope I just go into the state
and where they're not going to be able
to move
me push push good got it okay I'm just
relaxed I'm in the
state
so if she's pushing same thing it would
be by myself you come project you
see doesn't matter that there's two
different vectors here doesn't matter
I'm in that
state got it so that would be another
confirmatory confirmatory exercise if
I'm doing it right if I'm not bracing
I can be at multiple
angles do you got it
okay